she lived she served and she reigned
remembering the remarkable life of Queen
Elizabeth II welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight you know all eyes
are focused on Scotland in the UK as the
world Mourns the Monarch and the royal
family says goodbye to their beloved
Queen
a few moments ago Buckingham Palace
announced the death of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II the queen died peacefully
at Balmoral this afternoon I often draw
strength from meeting ordinary people
doing extraordinary things
shortly before the announcement at 10 30
a.m Pacific Time a rainbow appeared
opposite Buckingham Palace where crowds
gathered as the news rippled across the
globe and the Royals rushed to the
Queen's bedside at Balmoral Castle
that's Prince William stepping off a
plane in Scotland at 3 50 p.m local time
he was flown in from London and then
drove Prince Edward his wife Sophie and
prince Andrew to the castle
and then at 505 a flurry of flash bulbs
as senior members of the royal family
swept past us I could see Grim faces
Harry and Megan were supposed to attend
a charity event in London late today he
was spotted looking somber in all black
driven to Balmoral a source tells E.T
Harry went solo Princess Anne Charles
and Camilla were already on the ground
there the family Wanted Prince Harry to
be there even though he was unable to
get to Balmoral in time to see his
grandmother so I think that is deeply
significant that Megan was not invited
to join the family by the Queen's
bedside Kate Middleton stayed behind in
Windsor and was seen picking up George
Charlotte and Louis from school for them
to clear their schedules completely is
something they do not do lightly upon
hearing the news networks scrambled
Jenna Bush Hager who was already in
Scotland to interview Camilla had to
switch gears right before we were
supposed to meet her team came and let
us know that her Royal Highness Camilla
and Prince Charles had flown off to
about moral which is about at four hours
north of where we are Charles who was
named King Charles III released this
statement calling the Queen's death
quote a moment of the greatest sadness
for me and all members of my family the
brand new prime minister Liz truss went
live it's a huge shock to the nation and
to the world
this is the last photo of the 96 year
old meeting Trust on Tuesday she was
smiling and alert but using a cane you
can see some bruising on her hands she
hadn't been seen in public for 47 days
around 6 a.m Pacific Time BBC
programming completely switched to
report on the queen journalists changed
into all black clothing which is part of
a series of protocols in the event of
Her Majesty's passing had the queen
passed away in England operation London
Bridge would have been activated however
since the queen was at Balmoral it was
Operation unicorn the Unicorn being the
official national animal of Scotland
Parliament is immediately to be
suspended to prepare for the Queen's
State funeral the body of the Monarch
will be transported to Edinburgh to lie
in state at the palace of Hollywood
house Her Majesty's coffin will then be
carried to Saint Java's Cathedral so the
public can pay their respects the
Monarch will then be transported to
London where she will lie in state at
Westminster Abbey before making her
final journey to Windsor where she will
be interred with her late husband Philip
the Duke of Edinburgh your majesty Mommy
as the world Mourns many today are
asking about the line of succession and
a change in Royal titles it is more
likely than not that Prince William the
Duke of Cambridge will become the Prince
of Wales and Catherine in turn the
Princess of Wales we haven't had a
Princess of Wales since Diana and she
more than anyone will know that they are
sizable shoes to fill we will be
expecting to hear from the new king who
will address the nation tomorrow
I still view her more as the queen and
than my grandmother you you have this
huge amount of respect for for your boss
and um and I always view her as my boss
for a Time the queen seemed Unstoppable
a positive covet test in late February
sparked a week of worldwide concern but
her majesty returned to Royal duties
looking healthy during virtual
appearances at this reception at
Sandringham estate the queen in good
spirits stunned guests who were
expecting to watch her Cut the Cake
[Music]
a moment after a difficult year Royal
life slowed down for the queen after she
lost her beloved husband Prince Philip
in April of 2021. the two had been
married for 73 years for me in the
months since the death of my beloved
Philip I have drawn great comfort from
the warmth and affection of the many
tributes to his life and work
[Music]
viewed by many as serious and
old-fashioned she was actually quite
playful thank you Mr Prime Minister of
Canada for making me feel so old
[Applause]
[Music]
please
Elizabeth was known for her love of her
corgis almost all of her outfits were
custom made just for her in the 50s she
favored dresses cinched at the waist in
later years she went for coats and hats
always in bright colors so she could
stand out in a crowd
there are some disadvantages to crimes
once you put it on it stays and you
can't look down to read the speech you
have to take the speech up
because if you did your neck would break
would it fall off
she had a long connection with Hollywood
giving some of the biggest stars titles
from Dame Elizabeth Taylor to Sir Paul
McCartney and Sir Elton John she made
Angelina Jolie an honorary Dame of the
British Empire for her work on behalf of
refugees and we love that she didn't
seem phased at all when she met Lady
Gaga who happened to be wearing a Red
Rubber dress I was knighted by the queen
and she was lovely it's a sad day but I
feel good about Charles and welcoming
him to the throne
Queen will always be remembered as a
woman who made and lived through history
even in the unlikeliest of places hope
can still be found
[Music]